Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato Sambha samputassa
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sama Sambuddhasa Hommage to the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Donc, hommage à celui qui était veillé pleinement et par lui-même.
Donc cet enseignement que nous allons donner, c'est simplement pour revoir les choses les plus basiques.
Un peu pour nous rappeler ce que signifie vraiment l'attention juste.
Et je veux aussi juste aller plus en détail sur cette technique particulière.
Et je vais également rentrer un peu plus dans les détails par rapport à cette technique en particulier.
Pour bien comprendre ce que signifie l'attention juste, il est bon de revoir un peu ce qui s'est passé dans la vie du Bouddha.
Rappelez-vous qu'il a quitté la vie de famille pour deux raisons en particulier.
Et donc sa jeunesse était terminée.
Et après la jeunesse, la seule chose qu'on peut attendre de la vie, c'est la tristesse, la souffrance.
Donc...
Une des choses qui s'étaient passées pour lui, c'est qu'il était presque dégoûté d'avoir eu trop de plaisir dans sa vie.
Si vous vous souvenez, il s'est réveillé le matin après une fête, pour voir tout le monde de manière déchirée, et, vous savez, vomir, et tout ce genre de choses.
si vous vous souvenez de l'histoire un matin il s'est réveillé et c'était la fin d'une fête qui avait eu lieu toute la nuit et puis les gens étaient endormis c'était des postures dégoûtantes il y avait du vomi il y avait du vomi partout c'était vraiment la débauche un sentiment de dégoût par rapport à ça on a certainement tous vécu ça une fois donc c'était la première chose
Donc, c'était le premier déclencheur, c'est-à-dire ce manque d'intérêt qu'il a eu par rapport au plaisir.
Mais l'autre chose qui était à un niveau plus profond, c'était de réaliser que la vie offrait aussi la maladie, l'âge et la mort.
Mais à un niveau plus profond, il a pris aussi conscience d'autre chose, c'est que dans la vie, il n'y avait pas que les plaisirs, il y avait aussi le vieillissement, la maladie et la mort.
Et c'est ce qui a créé en lui ce qu'aujourd'hui on appellerait une crise existentielle.
Et dans ces jours-là, rappelez-vous, tout le monde, même dans l'Ouest aujourd'hui, tout le monde croit que
à cette époque-là, mais aujourd'hui encore, en Asie, dans cette partie du monde, on pense que la vie continue après la mort.
Donc la façon dont ils voyaient les choses, ce n'est pas seulement qu'après la jeunesse, il y allait avoir la maladie, la vieillesse et la mort, mais que ça allait reprendre.
Après la mort, il y aura encore la vieillesse, la maladie et la mort.
Et ça, à jamais.
Et donc, on peut dire que c'était vraiment la grande question, le grand problème de son âge.
Il s'est posé cette question.
C'était pas seulement sa question, c'était aussi la question qu'on se posait à son époque.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y avait beaucoup d'hommes, en particulier, qui quittaient la maison, qui quittaient une vie de famille, pour se lancer dans cette quête spirituelle, de comprendre comment sortir de ce problème.
Il y a apparemment eu trois efforts majeurs pour répondre à ce problème, à cette problématique.
Le premier était ce que nous appelions le matérialisme.
Et une des réponses était ce qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui le matérialisme.
Et donc cette façon de voir les choses, c'est ce matérialisme, c'est se dire ok, il n'y a que cette vie, il n'y en a pas d'autre après, donc on a intérêt à en profiter au maximum pendant qu'on le peut.
Il n'a pas l'air d'être attiré, il n'a pas l'air d'avoir été attiré par cette pensée particulière.
Mais il semble que le Bouddha n'a pas été attiré par cette façon de voir les choses.
Il y avait aussi une autre pratique qui se faisait à cette époque-là, c'est ce qu'on appelle les jhanas, c'est-à-dire les absorptions méditatives profondes.
Même en pratiquant sur la respiration, nous pouvons développer ces magnifiques états extatiques.
Quand j'étais en train de m'instruire la nuit dernière sur la respiration, je suis arrivé à un point où j'ai dit
Oui, si vous vous souvenez, quand je vous ai parlé de la respiration sur la respiration, j'ai dit, est-ce que vous pouvez sentir que la respiration est quelque chose de neutre, mais en même temps d'agréable ?
Et simplement rester avec cette sensation de la respiration, c'est quelque chose qui apaise le corps, qui fait du bien au cœur et qui met le silence dans l'esprit.
Et si on développe ça progressivement, ça devient un état d'esprit très positif, très beau, très agréable.
Et quand une personne devient très pratiquée à cela, elle n'a pas besoin de rien.
Et quand quelqu'un a vraiment l'habitude de pratiquer ces jhanas, on n'a plus besoin de rien.
On est bien.
Quand vous êtes dans cet état-là, que vous vivez en Asie, tout ce qu'il vous faut, c'est un bon arbre, un bel arbre, un bout de tissu pour vous couvrir, et puis un peu de nourriture de temps en temps.
Et c'est tout.
Donc...
On peut vivre de manière très belle et très paisible de cette manière.
Il semble qu'à l'époque du Bouddha, il y avait beaucoup d'ascètes qui vivaient de cette manière.
Et donc le Bouddha qui s'appelait Gautama à l'époque, il s'est aperçu que quand il sortait de ses états de félicité totale dans la méditation, il se retrouvait dans la même situation malheureuse, angoissée qu'il était avant.
Il ne pensait pas vraiment répondre à la question fondamentale sur si il y avait un vrai fin à toute notre insatisfaction et souffrance.
et il a eu l'impression qu'en fait ça ne répondait pas à la véritable question qui était peut-on vraiment mettre fin à ce sentiment d'insatisfaction et de souffrance qui nous habite alors il a essayé autre chose et ça c'était les pratiques d'auto-mortification c'est que le problème se trouve dans le corps
Et donc, ce que les gens qui pratiquent l'auto-mortification pensent, c'est que le problème, la racine de notre problème de souffrance est dans notre corps.
Par exemple, ils se disent que si on mange de moins en moins, si l'homme perd complètement l'appétit, on arrêtera de souffrir de l'avidité, de la convoitise.
Si vous restez loin de tout
Et si vous restez loin de toute tentation d'origine sexuelle ou autre, l'esprit va arrêter de s'agiter.
Et donc, il a pratiqué cette voie-là, et il est devenu très fort.
Il a dit qu'il pouvait tenir sa peau à travers son ventre.
Difficile, non ?
Donc, il a découvert, après quelques années de ceci, qu'il y avait juste plus de souffrance.
Donc maintenant, on peut imaginer qu'il quitte ses 5 compagnons,
Donc nous pouvons imaginer, là, il était avec cinq amis avec qui il pratiquait comme ça, puis il les a quittés.
Et là, il est dans une situation qu'on appellera aujourd'hui un désespoir existentiel.
Il ne peut plus retourner chez lui parce que là-bas, il n'y a plus rien qu'il pourrait considérer comme un véritable bonheur.
Toutes les pratiques que l'on pouvait trouver à son époque, il a essayé des enseignants, des ascètes, rien n'a marché.
Donc on peut l'imaginer assis au bord de la route et se sentant vraiment malheureux et désespéré.
Nous savons même son nom.
Et donc on me dit, on connaît l'histoire, une femme qui s'appelait Suchata, qui est passée à ce moment-là devant le Bouddha, et il se trouve qu'elle avait de la nourriture dans ses mains, qu'elle avait l'intention d'offrir à des déités, des déesses.
Mais je crois que c'était du riz-pouding.
everybody knows the salvific effect of rice pudding so she offers him this rice pudding and this revives him now it's just the interesting thing that at this point he remembers this
occasion in childhood.
Et là, à ce moment-là, il a eu tout d'un coup un souvenir qui lui remonte à l'esprit, quelque chose qui s'était passé dans son enfance.
Il se rappelle son père qui était en train d'ouvrir la saison de la moisson en faisant une cérémonie.
Maintenant, cela crée vraiment un point de tournée complet dans son recherche pour l'endroit de la souffrance.
Et là c'est vraiment un point crucial qui va faire tourner les choses dans sa recherche de la fin de la souffrance.
Donc il faut que nous essayions de nous représenter cet enfant qui avait 6, 7 ou 8 ans à peu près.
Maintenant, quand vous voyez un enfant devenir très intéressé par quelque chose, il y a une ou deux caractéristiques très évidentes.
Quand on voit qu'un enfant s'intéresse à quelque chose, il y a quelques caractéristiques assez évidentes.
La première chose, c'est que les yeux se fixent sur l'objet qui les intéresse.
Par exemple, s'ils découvrent pour la première fois une petite bête, ils vont voir les yeux qui vont se fixer dessus.
Et également les mâchoires qui s'ouvrent, qui se baissent.
ils ont l'air presque bêtes avec la bouche ouverte et le parent bien-sûr lui donne une claque sur la tête et lui dit réveille-toi un peu mais en réalité c'est un état d'absorption et il y a une caractéristique dans ça qui n'est pas inclus dans les absorptions qui apportent le délire
et il y a une caractéristique dans cette forme d'absorption qui ne fait pas partie qu'on ne retrouve pas dans les fameuses absorptions dont on parlait tout à l'heure qui apportent de l'extase et cette qualité la différence c'est la curiosité donc nous avons cette absorption cette très claire observation de ce qui se passe
Donc on a cette qualité d'absorption, c'est-à-dire cette observation très claire de ce qui se passe.
Et puis il y a ce désir de connaître, de comprendre.
Donc c'est avec cette détermination, avec ce souvenir de son enfance, où il se rappelait qu'il y avait cette curiosité en plus, qu'il a décidé qu'il n'allait pas bouger de cet endroit où il était, soit il allait trouver la solution à son problème, soit il mourrait.
Et c'était sa chance, c'était aussi la nôtre, en six heures, il a réussi à trouver la solution au problème.
Donc dans cette attention juste dont on parle, c'est cette qualité de vouloir trouver la réponse.
Et donc il y a deux parties.
et ces deux mots ils reviennent sans arrêt dans ce discours qui s'appelle comment établir l'attention juste donc il y a le mot sati qui en palie veut dire l'attention et il s'agit d'une attention ouverte et elle a en plus cette qualité d'équanimité d'égalité ce qui signifie que
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas tourné vers quelque chose que l'on chercherait cette qualité particulière c'est d'être parfaitement ouvert dans la tête et ouvert au niveau du cœur et dans ce regard que l'on porte il y a de la curiosité
Donc ceux qui ont entendu parler des sept qualités qui permettent d'avancer vers l'éveil, il y a le pitié qui est l'intérêt.
Peut-être qu'on en parlera davantage ce soir.
Donc, quand vous commencez à vous asseoir, si vous vous dites à vous-même, vous savez, qu'est-ce que j'essaie d'établir ?
C'est de vous poser la question et de vous dire qu'est-ce que j'essaie d'établir dans cette pratique.
Essayez d'amener à votre esprit l'image de cet enfant.
Et toutes ces techniques que l'on trouve dans toutes les écoles du bouddhisme, elles ont pour but de nous amener à cet état particulier.
Que ce soit Zazen, Shikantaza, Dzogchen, Vipassana, c'est toujours le même.
Ils tentent tous de nous amener à une position où nous pouvons observer, ressentir et expérimenter ce qui se passe d'une manière très directe.
Donc, le but de toutes ces techniques, c'est de nous permettre de ressentir, de voir, de comprendre de manière très directe ce qui se passe dans l'instant.
Donc, quand cela est clair dans notre esprit, on comprend mieux ce qu'est la technique de cette tradition et c'est de nous faire comprendre.
Donc, il y a trois techniques particulières pour cette tradition.
Dans cette tradition, il y a trois techniques particulières.
La première, c'est de noter.
Prendre conscience d'un mot, simplement.
La deuxième, c'est de ralentir.
Très lent.
Et la troisième, c'est d'être conscient de nos intentions.
Donc maintenant, notre plus grand ennemi est la tête.
et dans tout ce travail notre ennemi numéro un c'est l'esprit le mental les pensées, l'imagination dans le zen ils appellent ça le non-esprit donc les gens pensent que dans le zen on leur apprend à faire le vif de la tête mais ça veut dire simplement ne pas penser maintenant pourquoi est-ce que vous voyez
Et pourquoi ?
Pourquoi est-ce que c'est le problème ?
Parce qu'en réalité, tout ce qui nous passe par la tête, des pensées, des images, etc., ça représente notre relation avec des expériences passées.
Vous ne regardez pas cette épaule, vous regardez l'épaule sur laquelle vous avez mis toute l'histoire d'épaule.
C'est pourquoi quand vous la mangez, vous vous dites à vous-même que c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise épaule, ou qu'elle n'est pas si douce, qu'elle devrait être plus douce, et ainsi de suite.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle au moment où vous mordez dans cette pomme, vous n'êtes pas en train de la sentir, vous êtes en train de dire c'est une bonne pomme, c'est une mauvaise pomme, elle pourrait être plus douce, j'en ai mangé des meilleures.
Et de ce fait, on n'arrive jamais à être vraiment en train de goûter cette pomme telle qu'elle est dans l'instant.
C'est toujours en comparaison avec toutes les pommes qu'on a déjà pu manger dans le passé.
Ah.
Et c'est exactement pareil au niveau personnel.
Quand on connaît quelqu'un, on ne peut jamais les rencontrer comme on les a rencontrés au début.
On dépose toujours sur eux notre expérience que nous avons eue avec eux.
Donc comment revenir à cette
Donc comment revenir à cet esprit originel ?
Donc c'est une phrase qu'on emploie aussi dans le Zen, l'esprit originel, l'esprit du débutant.
Comment revenir à cette expérience de l'enfant qu'il voit pour la première fois ?
Bien sûr, notre position n'est pas la même qu'une enfant, parce que maintenant nous avons
Et bien sûr, nous ne sommes plus dans la position de l'enfant, nous ne sommes plus dans la même situation, puisqu'entre-temps, nous avons développé ce qu'on appelle une intelligence.
On dit dans le bouddhisme qu'un enfant en dessous de l'âge de 7 ans ne peut pas être éveillé, libéré.
À partir de 7-8 ans, oui, c'est possible.
Parce que, comme vous le savez, quelque chose se passe à ce moment-là.
Vous le savez certainement, il y a quelque chose d'important qui se passe à cet âge-là.
Déjà, on est beaucoup plus conscient des problèmes du bon, du mal et du bien, et donc la culpabilité commence à naître.
Et du coup, nous commençons à comprendre ce que signifie le karma.
Et le second point est que
Et la deuxième chose, c'est qu'on ne croit plus trop à ce qui se passe dans notre tête, notre imagination.
C'est pour ça qu'on ne peut plus croire que le Père Noël descend dans la cheminée.
Et ces deux grands changements font que notre relation au monde change.
Et donc, nous essayons quand même de continuer ce processus, de voir le mental qu'il est vraiment.
Alors, comment arrêter ce mental qui tourne en pensée tout le temps ?
Dans cette tradition, ce que nous faisons, tout cet intellect, nous le transformons, nous le mettons en un seul mot.
Par exemple, quand je fais la méditation en marchant, et au moment où je soulève le pied, je dis un mot.
Levez, levez, levez.
Et en fait, ce mot, il a pour but de retenir tout le mental.
le mental à ce moment-là il n'a plus la possibilité de penser au fait de lever le pied et de ce fait mon attention s'éloigne du mot qui n'a pas d'intérêt en lui-même et du coup je suis avec la sensation et la sensation elle, elle ne peut se produire que dans l'instant présent
Et c'est une expérience directe, de moment en moment.
Maintenant, une personne qui commence à noter peut sentir que le mot arrête de se sentir.
Il semble être juste ici, en levant, en levant, et le pied est quelque part ici.
il a le sentiment qu'il est dans la tête en train de dire lever, lever et qu'en fait pendant ce temps le pied il est quelque part en bas en fait ce que ça nous dit en tant que méditant c'est que notre attention intuitive elle est coincée au niveau de l'intellect la personne s'identifie complètement à sa pensée oui
je pense donc je suis.
Donc, en mettant toute notre attention sur la sensation, nous retirons la qualité intuitive de notre intelligence, de la pensée, nous la retirons de la pensée.
Et très lentement, le mot devient comme si c'était une note de fond, poussant l'attention vers l'objet.
Donc maintenant, quand le cerveau devient plus et plus serein, cette intelligence se déplace vers l'objet,
Et plus l'esprit se calme comme ça, plus cette intelligence qui se déplace vers l'objet d'attention devient stable.
Donc on dit très clairement dans le bouddhisme qu'on ne peut pas avoir deux moments de connaissance en même temps, on ne peut pas avoir deux pensées en même temps.
on peut avoir l'impression quand vous regardez un film et que vous mangez des sucres et que vous entendez et que vous voyez, ça semble tout se passer en même temps mais c'est la magie de l'esprit en fait, ce sont des consciences momentanées toutes mises ensemble
Il s'agit de plusieurs moments de connaissance qui sont rapprochés très proches les uns des autres et donnent l'impression d'avoir un fil continu de connaissance, de conscience.
Avez-vous vu des images très précises
qui montre comment l'œil bouge quand il regarde une image.
En réalité, pendant que nous croyons voir simplement une image, notre œil fait des tas de mouvements dans toutes les directions autour de cette image.
à chaque moment, ces petits pixels arrivent dans le cerveau et sont manufacturés mais ce que nous voyons, c'est cette image stable à chaque fraction de seconde, il y a tous ces pixels qui se rapprochent qui forment un motif et qui est pris dans le cerveau qui est traité complètement comme un ordinateur mais nous, tout ce qu'on croit voir, c'est simplement une image dans un instant donc quand nous notons qu'il y a deux moments très évidents de cognition ou de conscience
Il y a le ressenti et puis le notant, c'est la réflexion.
Même si nous disons « remontant, remontant » et il nous semble que le mot est concurrent avec le ressenti,
Même par exemple au moment où l'abdomen se soulève, on pense soulève, soulève, on a l'impression que le mouvement est parallèle au mot que l'on prononce, que l'on pense.
En réalité, la conscience est divisée en deux.
Il y en a une partie qui est en train de sentir et puis l'autre qui note, et l'autre qui sent, et l'autre qui note, et ça se rapproche très très vite.
Displacing the attention just on the feeling with the noting becoming ever more in the background.
Mais quand cette notation reste de plus en plus dans l'arrière-pensée et qu'on porte l'attention de plus en plus sur la sensation, there comes a moment when the mind, when that satipanya, that intuitive awareness locks into the present moment.
Et comme notre attention est sur la sensation, elle va se bloquer sur la sensation.
Et à ce moment-là, la note, elle s'arrête.
Et là, on appelle ça un moment de vipassana pur.
Hum.
ces instants sont parfois minuscules mais ils sont très puissants on ne peut pas les fabriquer, les forcer à venir si on force, on va dépenser trop d'énergie et ça va nous agiter
Et au contraire, la façon de procéder, c'est de se détendre en étant conscient de la sensation.
Et toujours avoir cet intérêt, cette curiosité.
Vous voyez l'enfant, dans cet instant de curiosité, complètement détendu, sa mâchoire s'ouvre.
La prochaine fois que vous verrez que vous êtes particulièrement intéressé par quelque chose qui soulève la curiosité, observez votre corps et voyez comme il est détendu à ce moment-là.
Je parle plus d'un merveillement dans la nature, pas devant un ordinateur.
Et c'est pourquoi le Vénérable Mahasi Sayado a développé cette technique particulière.
Ça peut être juste une note pour garder la tension bien stable, ou ça peut être plusieurs notes, ce suivant, ça n'a pas d'importance.
Par exemple, si vous vous sentez très fatigué ou endormi, ça fait du bien de noter, parce qu'en fait, pendant que vous notez, ça vous réveille, vous rassure.
Et si votre mental est très agité, si vous le notez aussi vite que ça se produit, ça vous évite de partir plus loin.
Maintenant, avec toutes ces techniques,
dans toutes ces techniques il y a toujours des choses qui vont nous inquiéter inutilement et un des problèmes par exemple c'est chercher le mot juste on s'aperçoit qu'on est en train d'essayer d'être des poètes au lieu d'être des méditants donc
donc pour noter, ne vous cassez pas la tête à chercher le mot juste n'importe quel mot qui va bien donner cette suggestion de ce que vous êtes en train de vivre, ça ira et on s'aperçoit au contraire que le langage est très cru pour décrire les choses
on n'a peut-être tellement de mots pour décrire des choses très subtiles des sensations subtiles donc on ne se casse pas la tête on va simplement utiliser le mot sensation ça ira très bien parfois vous pouvez noter ce que vous faites ressentir, ressentir, dans ce sens je suis ressentir, ressentir
Parfois ça peut être le mot sentir, je suis en train de sentir, sentir, sentir.
Donc ce n'est pas important combien de fois vous allez noter les choses, mais l'important il faut que vous sachiez que si vous notez, c'est pour maintenir votre attention bien présente.
Et le mot n'est pas important dans la mesure où il est proche de ce que vous ressentez effectivement dans l'instant.
Et la deuxième technique, c'est cette histoire d'aller doucement, très doucement.
C'est très simple parce que, comme vous le savez, plus vous allez, plus vous voyez.
C'est en fait très simple, parce que comme vous le savez très bien, plus on va lentement et mieux on voit les choses.
Par exemple, si vous faites le tour du parc en courant, si vous le faites en marchant, et si vous le faites en marchant très lentement, vous verrez bien que plus vous marchez lentement et mieux vous verrez le parc.
Donc, aujourd'hui, c'est difficile d'y entrer de façon complète, mais aujourd'hui, si vous voyez vous-même s'éloigner, arrêtez-vous.
Si vous sentez que vous vous bousculez, vous courez vers quelque chose, arrêtez-vous.
Arrêtez-vous.
Oui, laissez tout le système se calmer.
Et puis, on y va.
et puis vous repartez un peu plus lentement si par exemple vous entendez la cloche qui vous dit que c'est l'heure du thé ou quelque chose et vous sentez en vous cette poussée d'énergie ne bougez pas attendez
à ce moment-là si vous ressentez cette énergie qui vous pousse vers l'avant ne bougez pas, vous attendez dans la journée nous avons beaucoup d'actions répétitives par exemple ouvrir et fermer des portes faites de cela, de ce geste quelque chose de conscient faites quelque chose de délibéré
Au moment où vous la faites, vous savez ce que vous êtes en train de faire.
Et l'intérêt de cette chose, c'est que pendant qu'on est là, on n'est pas en train de projeter ce vers quoi on va, on est là, présent.
La main est déjà là et le corps arrive un moment après.
Par exemple, quand la cloche sonne pour le déjeuner, à l'instant où on entend la cloche, notre esprit est déjà là-bas, en train de déjeuner, alors que notre corps, lui, il arrive une minute après.
Donc, si vous voyez votre esprit qui va plus vite que votre corps, qui est déjà parti là-bas, lui dites, reviens un peu ici, reste ici, avance.
Donc, nous voulons aller dans la salle de dîner,
Et ensuite, nous nous rendons à l'esprit, vous voyez, et nous restons avec l'esprit, en allant à la salle à manger.
Donc, rappelez-vous, dans toutes ces méditations, l'importance de l'esprit nous met dans le moment présent.
Et dans toutes ces méditations, il faut bien prendre conscience de l'importance du corps, parce qu'il nous permet de nous enraciner dans l'instant présent.
Donc on ne vous demande pas d'aller très lentement tout le temps, mais à chaque fois que vous êtes seul, en particulier dans votre chambre par exemple, vous pouvez faire vraiment tous vos gestes très lentement.
Et rappelez-vous, ce sont ces petits temps entre lesquels nous ne pensons pas importants que nous perdons tous les bénéfices de notre pratique.
Donc, par exemple, après cette émission, nous ferons plus de méditations de marche.
D'ici à là où nous faisons la méditation de marche, c'est notre méditation.
Par exemple, après cet enseignement, nous allons aller faire de la marche en méditation.
Mais entre ce lieu et l'instant où on va commencer à pratiquer la marche formellement, c'est aussi de la méditation.
Donc, si vous êtes assis ici, et que c'est l'heure de faire de la méditation de marcher, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, allez-y
Donc vous êtes ici, bien calme, et puis vous allez méditer, vous courez vers votre endroit de méditation, et là vous posez, tout le moment vous posez, tous les bienfaits du calme que vous avez acquis avant sont perdus.
Et il faut se rappeler que tout ce que nous pratiquons ici, en ce moment, nous pouvons le pratiquer aussi au quotidien.
Donc ça c'est pour la question d'aller doucement, de faire les choses doucement.
Donc la troisième chose qu'on voulait voir, c'est noter l'intention.
Il faut se rappeler que le fait d'être conscient de notre intention nous permet d'avoir, de récupérer le contrôle sur nous-mêmes.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez vu le rapport qui prouve, en inverted commas, prouve
through these brain scans, that we make a decision before we know it.
Il y a soi-disant des rapports qui prouvent, entre guillemets, qu'en étudiant le scanner du cerveau, etc., qu'en réalité nous faisons, soi-disant, nos décisions avant même d'en être conscient.
Nous prenons des décisions avant même d'en être conscient.
So then we play a trick on ourselves and say, I decided to buy those chocolate biscuits.
Et après, on se joue un jeu en disant, j'ai décidé d'acheter ces biscuits au chocolat.
En fait, inconsciemment, vous l'aviez déjà décidé.
Et ça, c'est ce qu'on appelle la vie qui manque de présence consciente.
Ce qu'on va faire, c'est de rendre toutes ces intentions évidentes, claires pour nous.
Il y a un incident qui est relaté dans les commentaires autour des enseignements du Bouddha.
Il y a certains d'entre vous qui ont peut-être essayé de lire le Visuddhimagga qui signifie la voie de la purification.
C'est un commentaire sur les enseignements du Bouddha.
Et un enseignant parle
donc c'est l'histoire d'un enseignant qui pendant qu'il parle bouge la main à un moment donné sa main s'arrête et puis lentement dans le silence elle redescend et tous les élèves disent mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
il dit je n'ai pas été conscient de l'intention
Donc toute action que nous faisons, forcément, quelque part, il y a une intention.
Même le plus petit mouvement, forcément, a une intention derrière.
Donc sur un retreat comme celui-ci, nous essayons d'être conscients de toutes ces petites intentions que nous avons.
Dans une retraite comme celle-ci, nous essayons d'avoir conscience de toutes ces petites intentions que nous avons.
Une des choses que l'on remarque surtout, c'est toutes les intentions qui viennent de se passer, dont on n'a pas pris conscience.
L'intention est très très importante dans les enseignements du bouddhisme parce qu'on dit que c'est là que commence tout le processus de conditionnement.
C'est au niveau de l'intention.
Beaucoup de notre conditionnement n'a rien à voir avec nos valeurs morales.
par exemple quand je bouge les mains pour exprimer quand je parle ce sont des décisions sur le plan moral qui sont neutres mais quand ces intentions se déplacent sur un plan moral où il y a des décisions de type moral à ce moment là on peut créer des graves problèmes on peut créer aussi des belles choses
C'est pour cela que j'ai mis beaucoup d'accent sur le processus de la nourriture.
Le Bouddha lui-même était bien obligé de manger, n'est-ce pas ?
Il expérimente le goût de la nourriture, mais il n'experimente pas la grève de la nourriture.
Et on dit dans les Écritures, le Bouddha, il fait le ressenti, il ressent le goût de la nourriture, mais il ne ressent pas l'avidité pour la nourriture.
Il a conscience qu'une nourriture peut avoir du bon goût ou du moins bon goût.
Mais la relation qu'il a avec la nourriture, c'est qu'il ne recherche pas le bonheur ou le plaisir dans la nourriture.
On en reparlera plus profondément ce soir.
Vous vous entraînez à le faire tout le temps, du moment où vous vous réveillez jusqu'au moment où vous vous mettez à dormir, sans arrêt.
Donc cette technique de noter est quelque chose qu'il faut faire normalement tout le temps.
Depuis l'instant où vous vous réveillez jusqu'au moment où vous couchez, sans arrêt, sans arrêt.
Notez, notez tout ce qui se passe, tout ce que vous ressentez.
Au départ, ça demande pas mal d'efforts parce qu'on préférerait dormir sans nous l'enlever.
Et aller lentement, vous voyez, prendre notre temps avec tout.
Et puis il y a aussi cette technique de ralentir, prendre notre temps avec chaque chose.
Essayez de voir si vous arrivez à faire ça.
Vous arrêtez d'abord, prendre conscience de l'intention et puis agir.